he's the mayor of Los Angeles by the way
the IOC will award the 2024 Olympics and
Paralympic Games to Paris the 2028
Olympic and Paralympic Games to Los
Angeles the double award hasn't happened
in 100 years and I like that on his
first day in office
Eric Garcetti sent a letter to the USOC
asking to put LA in as the US city for
the next Olympic bid and lo and behold
here we are mayor and you got the
Olympics yeah good to have you back
great Tavi in Los Angeles and happy
Anniversary well thank you here's
explain the process of trying to sell a
city to the IOC to hold the Olympics and
also selling the city on why you want to
have the Olympics so I've been through I
don't know maybe ten political campaigns
this was the toughest one by far because
you only have about a hundred voters and
you have about four years of the process
it's almost like a high school election
you know like you have somebody over
here saying I don't like what you said
to Susie at the dance so you know I'm
not gonna vote for you or somebody else
saying you've only had drinks with me
ten times and Paris has done it twelve
times I need to sit down with you more
but you basically have to lay out why
your city should add something to the
Olympics it's not just what you'll do
for them but they also want to know how
the Olympics is gonna change your city I
think they really are idealist a lot of
them and they want to see what is it
gonna be that coming to LA is gonna be
different than Paris Hamburg whatever
but first before we even get there you
got to win the American competition to
be the American city and initially we
lost to Boston but when you're trying to
get the games bless it a hard sell
locally to to the residents to say that
this is not gonna change your life or
it's gonna make your life better and
rich your life how do you sell it not
here in LA I mean Olympics is in our
blood like I remember when I was 13
years old going to the Olympics and it
was the best experience of my childhood
I watched Carl Lewis and the 4 by 100
team set a world record I saw the world
on mice the streets of my city and so
here we had I think between 73 and 88
percent support in three or four
different polls I mean here even in LA
there's not 88 percent support for
sunshine came in at 75 percent so you
know we're doing better than mothers
that's a pretty amazing thing and so
when you go around the city so many
people coming up and go for the Olympics
we can do it and
and most cities it's rational not to bid
on the Olympics because why would you go
in debt spend billions of dollars for 17
days but here in LA we could do the
Olympics probably two months from now
I mean we're programmed we're ready we
have the sports facilities we've got
cycling we've got rowing we've got
archery we've got all these things here
year round unlike other cities that have
to build them and we've got at UCLA the
best athletes village which will be
built already because the UCLA campus
and you have the Olympic torch run and
you were kind enough to say that I could
run with the torch for at least a block
just let me know so I can let that
neighborhood know where I'm gonna be
running with it's actually by a
sanitation yard it's a recycling center
a lot of people but it's one block I
like that block yeah Danna tation we're
gonna call it I'm good with that will
you run with the Olympic torch sure yeah
I'll take the torch for me I think that
would be good no I definitely want to I
mean I won't be mayor in 2028 but I'll
be here as an Angeleno isn't that weird
though that you're you're trying to sell
something acquire something and then
you're not even here in the mayor yeah
the role of mayor well I told my
daughter Maya five-and-a-half I said I
want to do this for you it was the most
selfish thing I think I did as mayor
even though it's for her whole
generation it's for the whole city I
remember what it was like when she
thinks you're doing it for her I told
her all you got to do is win a medal to
make it up to daddy to figure out what
her sport is but I seriously you know
for me I think that it is you do a lot
of stuff that's for the future we passed
a measure we're talking about traffic
before here in Los Angeles to build 120
billion dollars and 15 new lines or
public transportation most that'll be
built when I'm gone
the Olympics will come after I'm gone
we're redoing our Airport and bringing
public transportation for the first time
when I'm gone
so my note to my successor is gonna be
just don't screw this cuz they'll get
all the good stuff when you become
president can we come to the White House
sure absolutely we can't and call me
Eric I can call you Eric people have to
call you mr. mayor no I insist my dad
once told me you have to know who you
are going into this business because one
day it's gonna be who you are going out
so it's always Eric explain something to
us because last time you are on you're
very candid you're a Rams fan you grow
up around
fan then they left broke your heart now
in the other back
you said you the city would have been
fine you would have been fine with one
team did you talk to anybody about not
letting the Chargers come in to Los
Angeles no I remember talking to mayor
of San Diego saying look I know you guys
are struggling trying to figure out a
way to keep them there and my heart's
with you same thing I said to the mayor
of Oakland and I know teams move and I
get it and you know people will embrace
the local teams especially if they start
to win you know I think over time
that'll be fine we had a little bit of a
claim to the Chargers because they
started here but really only one year
you know and I just I just knew it it
was like I spoke as a fan I got a lot of
calls from Chargers after that saying
you know what can we do said well you
know we love that you're here but I'm a
Rams fan and I think cities you know we
didn't need to go from 0 necessarily to
2
I'm glad to have both of them here but
you know I'm a Rams fan through and
through because I didn't know if people
thought you were misquoted because it it
felt like you were saying I love the
Rams we could have done without the
Chargers there was a partial days yeah
people were like you hate the Chargers
are fine no we love any team that's LA I
just have a ton of friends in San Diego
and I know what that feels like I
remember being a kid and and the Rams
left and for 20 years I'm watching TV
not even sure whether to root for them
that whole time you know I've been
reading for the Seahawks for the last
you know 20 years or so after they left
which is gonna make this Sunday
difficult for me but I'm gonna root for
the Rams over them but I just think that
you know sometimes it happens so quickly
it happens overnight and this business
is always about the bottom line I just
hope that the league in general can
really focus on the fans more he's the
mayor of Los Angeles
don't call him mr. mayor Eric Garcetti
adjoin is I don't know why I guess I
can't help but think of your father Oh
Jay got released from prison and any
phone calls with people asking what your
thoughts were of OJ not not that this
had anything to do with that what
happened with his ex-wife Ron Goldman
but just the history with your family
your dad you know I had my dad
participate in the because I had a
friend whose brother was the guy
producing the ESPN documentary and my
dad hadn't really spoken about it for 20
years he'd gone on he's a photographer
now he's a producer for the show major
crimes on TNT like he has a whole nother
chapter of his life and he asked you
think I should say my side of the story
I said yeah dad that's American history
I mean you should and you should teach a
new generation everything that was going
on cuz even though the verdict wasn't
what he wanted or what a lot of us
thought Oh J should have gotten my dad
used that as a way to raise awareness
about domestic violence at a time that
people weren't really talking about it
and I think you got to always bump that
up it's Domestic Violence Awareness
Month this month and you know I just did
a press conference yesterday and I
quoted my dad about a hundred percent
maybe 99% the guys on death row grew up
with domestic violence so you use these
moments to raise awareness my dad always
said of course oj got off for a crime he
committed
and the second one he was overcharged
probably but you know maybe it was karma
but now it's done does your dad second
guess have you ever had a discussion
where he second-guess himself with what
happened the first trial no he always
tells a story about the one guy who said
Oh Jay is gonna get off for sure was
former President Jimmy Carter he was in
LA a couple days before the verdict and
told my dad no matter what
Oh Jays gonna get off and my dad
couldn't believe him cuz he said no no
this is a clear case you know the
evidence is strong and Jimmy Carter just
said look it's after years and years and
years of of miscarriage of justice on
the other side this will be payback
trust me
watch it he's gonna get off and my dad
always said he kind of feels like he was
maybe a little naive he thought it was
just a straightforward case as a
prosecutor looking at it but it's such
an extraordinary case it had to do with
celebrity it had to do with race it had
to do with all these things over the
years it wasn't just the evidence what
do you think changed the LA Police
Department more Rodney King or OJ
Simpson Oh Rodney King for sure when
when this city blew up it was a moment
which we had to really dig deep and not
just the police department but the
entire city you know when I watched
Ferguson happen I kind of thought thank
God we're not a better City than
anywhere else but we went through 20
years earlier
I mean before social media somebody had
a video cassette and taped what happened
and it caused us to reform ourselves
become better the police department
looks like LA now comes from our
neighborhoods we've got civilian
oversight we still screw things up we're
human beings but we have a much more
resilient system to deal with it whereas
a lot of other cities are just beginning
to figure out how do you do that how do
you get the
we appreciate you come in coming in I
looks like you might have something
there you have a folder looks like it's
pretty official I'm hoping you have
something therefore I got I got right
here for you guys
Oh a little certificate congratulations
Dan and the Dan that's ten years right
here City of Angels this will allow you
to park anywhere just be careful because
there's you know Beverly Hills isn't
part of the city of La Culver City isn't
part of the city I put on my dashboard
yeah put on your dashboard it gets you
through the lanes really easily and and
call me if you're in jail tonight
I do have vanity plate I don't have a
van you ever have a vanity plate I've
never but I want to get one for the
Olympics when we get one and what are
you gonna get I don't know maybe just
get the original one says la 2028 but do
you think somebody's already got that
maybe now that I just if you if you want
it I'll just do la 20:29 then that's
great
listen here the plaque is great thank
you so yeah you go Dodgers tonight baby
let's get it done are you going to the
game I'm not gonna go tonight but I will
get probably the next one on Saturday
are you diehard Dodger fan I am a
die-hard Dodger fan and I'm worried
because they you know the backs have had
our number this year but I think we'll
do well in the first two games given
their pitching rotation right now what's
the coolest thing you've ever done as
mayor sports wise winning the Olympics
for sure
question you know it's it's actually
small stuff I'll tell you what it was it
was last weekend I think the coolest
thing I did was after 30 years I got to
go to an opening of an archery range
with a bunch of archery fanatics the
Easton's you know the eastern company
that does the baseball bats and stuff he
was an international impact committee
member open it up and I got to
officially open it up by having a bow
and arrow and I had you know I don't
know maybe ten bull's-eyes and three or
four around it and people were very very
scared and I liked to have that fear win
wait wait you had bull's-eyes yeah it
was the coolest experience I I had an
art since I was in high school probably
Wow Paulie is an archer for Archie I was
an archer yeah
longbow oh yeah that was pretty cool I'm
but look I got TV you could open the
Olympics with it yeah like the Oh like
the guy did it yeah oh you could shoot
the flame actually the best was the
Kings a guy said when the Kings won yeah
triple overtime there might have been a
little rally afterwards were did you get
to hold the cup I got to hold the
country drink out of the cup I haven't
drunk out of the cup but I did I did
have a little controversy at the winning
when I said there's two rules and
politics never be pictured with alcohol
I never swear but I said but this is a
big I always tell kids if you're gonna
swear you do it positively it's a lesson
to be learned there don't call me mr.
mayor he's Eric Garcetti and
congratulations thank you that's nice
thank you very much double digits the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience